Oh, Oh, Hihi, Ouhou
ça le fait pas, ça le fait pas. Non ça marche pas
Mais tiens, prends ça.
T'es ... t'es sûre ? Parce que je ... je vais te déboiter avec ça, tu vas voir...
Ok ...
Mama mia !!!
Hein, hein, ... hein hein
J'sais pas. Essaie de sauter, peut-être dedans, je ...
Ouais nan là c'est ridicule ...
Tu kiffes là ?
Ouais ouais ...
C'est cool
Cool cool cool cool cool ....
Oh la la
Oh la la, Oh la la
Aaaahaaaahaaah
Ahhhh
On en parle à personne, hein ?
Oui t'inquiete pas...
Vas-y casse moi tout là-dedans, Zelda !
Nan mais putain, mais putain ! Moi c'est Link !
Zelda c'est un nom de meuf et Zelda c'est toi. Tu fais ça tout le temps .... C'est chiant.
Si je dis que t'es Zelda , t'es Zelda ! Ok ?!
Ok ...
J'suis une princesse ! J'suis ta princesse.
Sauve moi ! hihihi
Oui ! oui oui ...
Nan. Nan ...
Nan, y'a un truc, un truc qui va pas là. J'ai l'impression qu'il manque un truc ...
Hé hééé !!